cinéma avec un film pour les enfants à
quelques semaines de noël lucky luke
qu'on retrouve dans tous à l'ouest
dessin animé entièrement français est
réalisé en 3d pour le dessin pas de
surprise vous connaissez bien sûr le
héros et son cheval jolly jumper
mais pour la bande-son ce sont des stars
qui ont prêté leur voix
marie-hélène bono francis forget pour
nom et lutte
lucky luke jeudi j'ai vu ce qu'ont pris
quelque part c'est l'homme qui tire plus
vite que son ombre
tout le monde commet du clip les albums
cultes et de morris et goscinny 205
millions d'exemplaires vendus
le film tous à l'ouest même s'il n'est
pas tirée d'une seule histoire s'inspire
largement de la caravane paru en 1964
tous les personnages y sont
le célèbre cow-boy rantanplan j'ai
trouvé au mètre carré pour un dépôt les
daltons relais et châteaux sotchi jo et
toute une série de figures euros ce qui
est intéressant en dessin animé c'est
comme ça s'étale sur du temps si on veut
changer encore un plan si on veut bouger
on peut l'histoire commence par une
course poursuite dans les rues de new
york
les dalton s'évade et braque une banque
ils perdent leur magot au milieu de la
caravane que lucky luke emmène à l'ouest
un road-movie plein de gags et de
rebondissements une tuque
il a retrouvé le rythme en un dessin
animé fabriquée entièrement à paris 18
mois de travail plus de 200 mille
dessins et une pléiade déjà d'être
traitent leurs voix aux personnages
alors c'est vous lucky luke c'est moi
dans mes rêves parce que sur un jour on
m'avait dit que j'étais petit que je
fais ça je pense que c'est vrai c'est le
plus beau jour de ma vie je crois répond
nous prendrons un chemin sûr et
tranquille
nous traverserons la pennsylvanie l'ohio
l'indiana l'illinois le missouri le
kansas à tâtons de danon vide at-on
jamais donner la patte qu'on marche j'en
ai donné lapin pas qu'en marche
enfin maurel centricois pour un ancien
des siens de faire un temps plein c'est
un nouvel os à ronger ses dessins animés
d'une réussite s'adresse aussi bien aux
enfants qu'aux adultes
en attendant le film avec jean dujardin
yeux
oui